[Musique]
diabète mes camarades c'était en 2015
pour les périmé était en campagne pour
les élections de la CTM et ben nous
disons NON
oui du canton de cette Marie ancienne
conseillère générale elle appelait à
voter pour ensemble pour une Martinique
nouvelle je demande au samaritain
et de voter pour la liste ppm de Serge
la chimie était une proche de Bruno
nestora0 entre 2012 et 2015 c'est elle
qui lui succède au conseil général et
selon les syndicalistes elle était en
négociation avec le maire pour obtenir
une rupture conventionnelle de son
contrat d'employé de la collectivité
l'eau de son évaluation au mois de
janvier 2022 elle a été entretenu et
signé par son N+1 N+1 si comme Monsieur
le Maire excellente agent on a du mal à
comprendre
pourquoi on arrive aujourd'hui à cette
situation préférant laisser des
syndicalistes s'exprimer à sa place pour
l'aide périmé poursuit sa greffe de la
faim elle sera entendue lundi prochain
par un conseil de discipline qui devra
décider de son sort quand au maire de
cette Marie il a refusé tout interview
il devrait s'exprimer lundi après ce
conseil de discipline